President Biden is in Northern Ireland
celebrating the Good Friday peace
agreement made 25 years ago the
president met with Britain's prime
minister and other political leaders
this morning before starting a three-day
visit to the Republic of Ireland Ed
O'Keefe is in Belfast traveling with the
president Ed good morning
Vlad good to see you the president's
speech is expected to be forward-looking
and it's designed to reiterate United
States support for Northern Ireland but
the speech at this University in Belfast
comes amid concerns about renewed
sectarian violence potentially between
Catholics and Protestants
President Biden arriving last night in
Northern Ireland to Mark the 25th
anniversary of a key peace agreement
of the Good Friday Accords have been
scarred by renewed threats of violence
and political instability on Tuesday
just hours before Mr Biden's arrival
local police say they discovered four
pipe bombs in the town of Londonderry
Police believe the bombs were left
behind by Catholics opposed to British
rule the President says sustaining the
agreements and avoiding a return to the
troubles is his top priority this week
keep the peace that's that's the main
thing and it looks like we're gonna keep
your fingers Ireland's ambassador to the
United States Geraldine Byrne Nason
having the United States walk with us as
we work make progress and walk forward
together that's really important to the
people of Ireland most of the
president's week is devoted to stops
across Ireland to celebrate his Irish
heritage as presidents have before him
the brightest days will continue to be
those in which we visited you here in
Ireland I've come home
to find the apostrophe that we lost
somewhere along the way he'll stop in
county louth home to ancestors on his
mother's side and Friday he heads to the
Tiny Town of bolina where his father's
side is from the town is a sister city
of the president's native Scranton
Pennsylvania where Mr Biden still has
distant cousins desire shoots a really
deep Miss Harris he said it always said
like when he when he became president he
was always going to come back to
now the president earlier this morning
had just a quick morning coffee meeting
with the British prime minister leading
one British official equipped to the New
York Times that it wasn't the larger
more formal bilateral meeting they
wanted but instead just they buy latte
meeting get it it's the president
insists he meant no snub and the British
prime minister is expected to visit
Washington this Summer Gail
Guess what at everybody in the studio
got it including Klaus we all got it
thank you Ed thank you so much that was
good